what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel before I start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
today I am going to be reacting to
something and typically I really don't
like reacting to hit pieces like as you
guys know there have been many hit
pieces made on your girl pearl and for
the most part guys for months these
people have just been making hit piece
hit piece hit piece and I just ignore it
but today I am going to be reacting to
I've been preach's hit piece on me
um a legend this is what I've heard I
actually haven't even seen it so
let's let's pull up the clip pull it up
okay why do you think they're getting
divorced do you think divorce is fun I
think women divorce for no reason all
the time I do think that yeah
actually a child what do you think okay
one isn't that a bit rude see this is
the thing when they don't have a good
argument you're gonna call me a child
that's a bit rude it's a bit rude yes
you're just like romantically going away
to Venice like every year and that's
like like no well relationship requires
a lot of deliberate work things like
chores and where relationships start to
break down and it'll steamroll into
bigger things the whole argument is I
think divorce is stupid over chores I
think that's stupid when you have a
house there's a lot of choice there's a
lot of [__] to do around the house a lot
and she works all day bringing that
paper that's that and then she goes home
and she's still gotta do some work it's
gonna it's gonna take a toll and she
doesn't feel like it's separated our
work like that [__] it doesn't she
doesn't feel like the the the the work
is equally separated at home it's gonna
be a burden it's definitely gonna be a
burden and see like this is the thing a
lot of these reaction channels will try
to nitpick and they'll be like well if
she's working the chores are going to be
hard guys marriage is supposed to be
hard
um and I've told this story like many
times on my channel so I'm just gonna
tell it again
um my there's a relative of mine and um
this relative was married for 50 years
and um this woman did not believe in
divorce like it it was just not an
option in her book and her husband
actually left the family for another
woman and she she prayed to God for a
solution because that that was her
belief she did not believe in mayor
sorry she did not believe in divorce so
her husband
um leaves and the side chick died now I
know everyone's gonna say she killed her
I swear to God I swear she did not she
did not but this is the thing like he
came home and she didn't throw it over
his head she asked where they went wrong
in the marriage and how they could fix
it and that's the thing like a lot of
times people on our generation are so
quick to throw in this in the towel like
people used to have their husbands go to
war and it would make it work where he
would be gone for a year at a time and
nowadays we're we're getting divorced
over what a messy house chores look all
day you have to go home then you have to
click you have to cook then you have to
clean then you have to put the kids to
bed then you have to but do you hear how
spoiled we are do you hear how spoiled
this sounds like people used to get
divorced for real reasons like the death
of a child you know my husband's
mistress and now it's because you're
frustrated over a messy house all things
so you're constantly draining you could
do that for a whole last week and then
you won't care because you know the
passion of the couple but after a couple
of weeks it's really fast for you to be
drained you figured yourself what about
drinking but but that's a choice you you
can allow it to drain you or you cannot
and you know I've lived with all
different types of people I swear I
always have different roommates in
college
um and it really is a choice at the end
of the day because and I grew up with
nine siblings nine I'm telling you [__]
can be worked out of 24 hours you work
18. it's a place where I'm supposed to
rest I don't feel like I'm rested I feel
like I'm always doing the job not only
but see but see listen to him talk me me
me me
me before the family me first I'm this
I'm that I'm that but what about your
kid what about the children and this is
the problem with a lot of these reaction
and like commentary channels is you know
they look at it with a me perspective
instead of the family first and all the
money I'm coming back home and I still
gotta work yeah it's gonna be a pro it's
gonna definitely gonna be a problem and
[__] are gonna be like you know
what I'm gonna get me someone that's
actually a partner when you have a
Caribbean mom or that's most mom I guess
they come back home and one thing to be
complain yo yo you guys are ungrateful
you never helped me I do everything
about that's what they talk about if
your mama see
works and she brings a bill you don't
bring anything in the house she's going
to feel like you're not doing anything
and you're not bringing anything in the
house yeah but what percent of women can
fix a car what percent women do the yard
work
like a lot of time women will keep score
but we don't talk about what the men do
it's always about all we do for them but
we a lot of times women don't even
realize how much men do for us and I'll
give you guys an example okay when I was
younger my dad he worked a lot
um and it was actually really hard for
me when I was younger because he would
go to India for like weeks at a time you
know so it's like half the month my
dad's not even there at one point when I
was younger and don't get me wrong I was
gone a lot too because I played Sports
so I wasn't you know just him but I
remember there was a time in like my
childhood where I I questioned like you
know if if my dad loved me and my mom
just looked at me and she said are you
kidding me do you see all the stuff he
did for it does for you and you know I
was like 12 at the time right and I was
like but Mom he's gone or whatever and
she's like
um you just got out of volleyball what
did he do he pulled the car up for you
oh he just took your bags to the car he
he pays for this he pays for that like
and she just um she humbled me so hard
like well she just listed every single
thing that my dad did for me in the past
like 24 hours and I realized and I think
this is common with women where we don't
see a lot of times like the stuff that
men do for us day to day because we
don't notice it and we just start
counting and keeping score of all the
stuff we do for them instead of looking
at what they do for us but again this
goes back into the problem with the
culture is it's me me before the family
that's what she wants so yeah I could
believe that
and the other thing is why if you
believe in divorce over chores why get
married just be in a relationship like
the what happened to marriage vows for
better for worse for sickness and in
health for richer or for poorer those
are marriage for doing the chores and
not doing the chores so it's like if
you're really marriage minded and
believe in what marriage is supposed to
be you know getting divorced over chores
isn't an option you're constantly
thinking of solutions but a lot of these
people they don't believe in Real
Marriage not the way it's supposed to be
um I mean at that point just be in a
relationship don't get married
a big ass burden to someone when they
come back home and they want to commit
divorce you got that right yeah I think
the only way you could ever think that
is if you haven't ever lived with anyone
and you've got to live with a
significant other that's the only way
you could talk like that hell roommates
forget forgive a significant other y'all
ever lived with roommates and see this
is the thing they go into personal
attacks and now they're trying to
insinuate I've never lived with the guy
they're trying to insinuate I I've never
had roommates which it's actually funny
because I grew up with nine siblings
like I nine who who's lived with more
personalities than me my dad's one of
13. uh my mom's one of nine most of
their brothers and sisters are married
so um on top of that that's the thing
like a lot of times they'll go personal
instead of attacking the argument is it
good for a society to get divorced over
chores is that good
um are there exceptions no don't get
married that's my opinion on it there's
no point in getting married if you
believe in getting divorced over chores
a person doesn't do they they don't
clean after themselves they don't pay me
and I'd like to say um
I live in a way because
um a lot of people don't know this I've
actually never lived alone now that I'm
thinking about it I've lived I always
had roommates in college um when I
wanted to start my YouTube channel I
lived with a couple from a church for
200 a month to save money to do it and
then now even when I do live alone I
actually live with a bunch of people
that work here basically and and I do
shows six days a week where there's
people in and out so again it's like a
personal attack when they don't know
anything about you they're not attacking
the argument because they don't take any
of the trash out they don't do nothing
they just leave their [__] around no
hold on it's not even that you don't
just do anything is that they create
more for you to have to do the mother
left his dishes in there wait for
somebody else to do them and then on top
of that I can respect it if you paid
something extra I could respect it if
you do the trash or something you did
nothing and you left me extra okay and
that this is the me me mindset like the
other thing is over a lifetime men make
more than women I know some young women
make more but when you think about it do
women really want to be working that
hard in their 50s and their 60s I mean
ideally you'd be with a man that would
want to get you a plan to stay home when
you're older but it's just a lot of
times these reaction channels and
um you know people with with this more
like modern mindset they they believe
it's me before the family it's my
feelings before the family when a lot of
times there's kids involved it's not
about you anymore and you pay the same
amount so you paid you have the same
amount but you bring it to labor it's
just like be you did all this and on top
of that you're going to pee on the
[__] no pick up your piss [__]
why should I pee the [__] is this then I
gotta and another question I have why
would you take marriage vows if you
don't know if the person's clean or
messy what that doesn't make any sense
to me I could tell you which of my
friends are clean and which ones are
messy I could tell you which ones I
would live better with and which aren't
without even living with them so it's
just a lot of like in my opinion a
victim mentality oh how did I end up
taking serious vows and then getting
divorced over what chores you need to
clean this too yeah of course you're
gonna be pissed off everybody gotta do
they part when you get when you get
older and you manage a household on your
own Pearl you'll see how annoying it is
when you're working and then you come
home and everything is horrible and
nobody's pickling anything yeah that is
a totally valid reason for divorce of
course yeah chores to break up a home
her family have you lived in a filter
but see that's what they do they go
personal they go personal we'll have you
have you you have never done like and
that's the thing like what is the
argument what is the actual argument
here is it good to get divorced over
chores is that good for a society is
that a good message and this is what
they'll do is they'll say oh well but
but this but that but that then then
don't get married that's my argument why
would you get married and take those
vows if you believe in divorce over
chores and I think all in all people
forget that marriage is a vow it's a
commitment
um yeah anyways
if it is consistent what you'll
consistently having to have that burden
upon yourself you keep telling them
please can you a lot of these people who
have these podcasts don't know what the
[__] they talking about they don't
actually have the experience so they
read up on it like nerds not knowing
what the lived experience is actually
like what the work is actually necessary
is easy to say chores but you ain't
never have to listen if your home is
filthy and don't feel like home if your
home is a place where you just have more
work than [__] you on the job 24 7. so
you take a chance off to get right back
on the shift at home who wants to go
home at that point right so it's like yo
not having go home after a long day of
work that is you if you rob someone of
that that will take a toll in no time
it's not going to take long y'all ever
have your own place and then your mom
gotta stay over for a week how long does
it take before you want your mom to get
the [__] out of your weekend she cleaned
it she might even be cooking but by the
end of it bro I want my home to be a
[__] home and not my mom looking over
my shoulder telling me when I'm picking
up my underwear when I want to be don't
say that because that's your mom be
respected but you get what I was trying
to say
on the inside
all right
disrespectful if you say it but you can
think it oh no and I don't thought a
whole bunch of the the number of times
you went to your roommate yeah yeah
you're gonna be like
what happened nothing it don't take long
yeah yeah it don't take long for your
home tonight you want them gone yeah so
if there's significant others coming in
and creating that mess and doing all
this other stuff yeah it's like it's
like here's the thing if you care about
me why don't you just do your part like
she over there stressed because she
gotta do all this extra [__] and you
sitting there on the couch yeah but he
he could be stressed because he has to
take care of the yard and this is the
thing like they always go personal oh
these people that have these podcasts
don't know what they're talking about
um could you pull up the other video
king so now where where do these
opinions of mine come from this is like
a common question I get
um so there's there's two ways you can
kind of look at your view and the world
you can look at through what you see in
your lived experience you can look at
stuff online and you can look at studies
so first I want to show you guys a
conversation that I had with an antibine
and this ant is genuinely one of those
kind sweetest most feminine women that I
know so she's been married to her
husband for 20 years they have two
beautiful kids and honestly she really
is an example of like the kind of wife I
would want to be
um so so this was a while ago this was
um like two years ago but again like
people ask me where I get my opinions
from so this is this is one of my aunts
now again my dad's one of 13 my mom's
one of nine most of my relatives are
married my parents are married they've
been married 20 years they started a
business together you know even that
lived experience is more than half of
kids nowadays in the west even just
seeing a functioning adult relationship
so it's funny like a lot of the and I
don't know their personal backgrounds
but a lot of the reactors that are
saying or the people that are saying oh
you have no lived experience they've
never seen a functioning healthy
relationship they grew up in a lot of
these people have grown up in single
mother homes and I have a son named
Roman he's um almost 16. but they're
kind of not very and they leave things
around I want to just say this they're
slobs I hope they don't get mad but they
are and they used to leave socks laying
around they get so frustrated Hannah but
I had to change my mindset and I thought
these socks are I love you notes so I
would pick up a sock and I'd say Roman
loves me Jason loves me and it really
changed I never got mad about it I just
did it right well that's fine and so you
gotta change your mindset and think good
things and I Jason has gotten more
organized over the years and I've helped
him because I'm really OCD and
perfectionistic and my daughter is just
like that mm-hmm
Roman is just like his dad and that's
just how they're wired now that doesn't
mean to say I can go in the shop and
tear apart a mood or a radiator I can't
do that so they have skills I don't have
right so I'm not putting them down I'm
just saying we all have our talents
right but find somebody a good man or am
I giving men advice both okay a good man
and a good woman that have good
communication and do not play games okay
so what mindset is better this mindset
where she's literally teaching herself
to look at picking after her husband and
her son as a way that she loves them or
is it better to just get divorced over
chores and you know you know what's so
beautiful about that she starts to
recognize you know what they're good at
things that I'm not because oftentimes
like with women it's like we have to get
off our high horse we're not perfect and
a lot of times we don't realize the
stuff that men are doing for us so go
back to the reaction before she's not
happy like how much do you really care
if you let your partner having to take
on all that burden and you don't even be
out there trying to help in a tangible
way you know I mean like like you pretty
much just saying [__] you every day to
your partner like if I was mine and they
saw me struggling with something on my
back you best believe they'd help they'd
be like yo let me carry some of that
wait if they did it is watch me
struggling the whole time yeah but I was
struggling with your bag why don't you
just hire someone to pick up your bags
you know why you're already that's it's
like how much do you really care that's
a weird response but do you see the
difference in the mindset King you see
that where where he's like how much do
you really care where my aunt someone
that's been married will say you know
what they're good at different things
everyone's different we all have our
strengths and our weaknesses like what
what is better what mindset's better for
a long-term marriage seeing your partner
struggle I ain't gonna do it like
lifelong friends from like grade school
to high school well dormant college and
then hate each other forever over like
bad dorm roommates and that's not even a
relationship so yeah of course I think
stuff like this is perfectly valid I
think I think I mean
but that goes to the modern mindset it
shouldn't if it doesn't work out living
with someone you shouldn't go to hating
each other anyways
my duties in the households like what
are the most important parts of like a
relationship because it's where you're
spending most of time together this is
why I say people get trigger and I say I
don't think you're even dating until you
live together because until you live
together you don't really know what the
other person's like and once you start
living together and you see what the
household duties are like then you get I
do think that duties roles and
responsibilities are important I will
give you that I do think it's important
but again I'm not really attacking like
what he's saying it's more of the
mindset behind it the relation
and for also for a guy that's big on
stats okay I got this is the stat man
because again number two right then then
so I feel like most opinions will come
from lived Real World Experience second
thing is studies when you're not sure
you look at studies I'm going to read
this this is from CBS News all right
does the site of men doing traditional
female chores turn women off a new study
suggests that the more time men spend on
household tasks the less sex they have
our findings suggests the importance of
socialized gender roles for sexual
frequencies and heterosexual marriage
lead author uh sarbino korich junior
researcher at the center for advanced
studies at the Juan March Institute in
Madrid said in a press release couples
in which men participate in more
household work typically done by women
report having sex less frequently
similarly couples in which men
participate more in traditionally
masculine tasks such as yard work paying
bills and auto maintenance report higher
sexual frequency this study was
published in the February edition of the
American sociological review
surveyed 4 500 heterosexual married
couples from 1992 to 1994. the average
age for the men was 46 in the women 44.
now now the studies study backs me up
I'm just you know don't don't shoot the
messenger relationship I mean I just I
just think that like I don't I feel like
that stuff can be worked out chores when
you say it could be worked out what do
you think those women ask their husbands
to do do you think their husbands didn't
do the trash for a week and they said I
want a divorce is that what you really
think happens of course not this is
something that drags on over an extended
period of time and there's a lot of
toxic conversations about this I feel
exhausted can you do some of the extra
labor can you do this can you do that
can you do that it never just happened
but see okay wait pause it pause it
pause it that mindset what can they do
for me what about what you can do for
them why do we always assume that people
talking really did more like we always
assume oh but like maybe we always
assume that the person talking is in the
right so when she says oh what did what
could he do more for me why can't you do
more chores well why can't she pay more
bills why can't she do more of the yard
work why can't she fix more stuff around
the house it's like we always assume
that the women is women are in the right
and I just want to read I just want to
read marriage vows just just to remember
because again I'm not arguing that you
can't break up over chores I'm just
saying then don't get married because
I'm gonna I'm gonna read some marriage
vows okay I'm just this is from the
church of England
um just uh because I'm in England you
know I'm Catholic but I take you so and
so to be my wife slash husband to have
and to hold from this day forward For
Better or For Worse for richer or for
poorer in sickness and in health to love
and to cherish till death do us part
according to God's holy law in the
presence of God I make this vow For
Better or For Worse in sickness and in
health for richer or for poorer not when
you didn't do the chores if you want to
break up with someone over tours then
don't get married that's my argument
then you might as well be in a
relationship take out the trash for two
weeks yeah nobody it I don't care who
you are nobody is like that and I say
this only because I know guys who their
wives work and they fully feel entitled
to their women doing all the labor at
home this is very normal especially from
immigrant back you know with the kind of
way that times you're going right now
women are having to work because one
man's income is not enough to support a
family so both parties yeah these guys
still are by the old rules where even
though they make sometimes less money
they still expect her to do all the
labor because that's the rules so I'm
not going to act like these women are
crazy when they what percent of okay I'm
just gonna give you guys an example what
percent of men know how to do dishes
what percent of men know how to I don't
know clean the house what percent of men
know how to cook and I don't have any
studies on this so you can just ask this
in your own life anecdotally now what
percent of women know how to change a
tire what percent of women know how to
mow the lawn what percent of women know
how to fix anything what percent of
women know how to change their oil now
this is just anecdotal and you could say
I don't have enough life experience but
when I look at the boys in my house and
the girls in my house I would say that
more of the boys know how to do that
stuff and then the girls know how to do
that stuff vice versa
and I would say this in general just
friends people I know more men know how
to clean up than women know how to fix a
car or change a tire or do any of the
traditionally masculine role just my
opinion take it or leave it your choice
I can imagine that's just annoying
because I've had roommates I've had
relationships and I could tell you if
somebody don't pick up their weight that
[__] will eat at you man or woman me me
me me first if somebody doesn't listen
if you're in a relationship as a man and
you find out your girl ain't been
cooking cleaning or doing none of that
you know you're gonna be salty so why
don't you think she's gonna feel the
same way when you make her also have to
take a job like hold on wait do you
understand
you're not saying anything oh you do
this intentionally where you're like I
don't know about that
see that's a bit rude that's a bit rude
I mean I think that's kind of rude to
come on someone's show and like that's
disrespectful actually but um I said
that I don't think that you should get
divorced over chores and I will stand on
that that you could disagree with that
stance you could say but that that
breaks my inner peace but I think if
you're gonna take a marriage vow a
marriage vow and you genuine genuinely
believe that marriage is supposed to be
for richer for poor and sickness and in
health and For Better or For Worse and
you believe that you should get divorced
over chores that in my humble opinion
you should just be in long-term
relationships and not get married or
have kids just my opinion
we're telling you I'm telling you that I
mean you're giving your opinion I'm
giving I'm not giving an opinion I'm
saying that in a household this is not
an opinion
back in a house delineation of chores is
one of the most important things that if
somebody's constantly destroying the
bathroom leaving clothes everywhere
leaving dirty food in the sink they
can't clean their their dishes or
whatever so it's like destroying the
bathroom what a great way to say bro
you're taking a big old [__] you know
I'm saying I think of bathroom
destruction
back down but see he's like moving the
goal post that's like what he does is
he's like well household chores
delineation is really important I'm like
okay it's important but is it a reason
to get divorced like that's the whole
point is it a reason to get divorced I
walked in and I'm like yo [__] did you
leave your [__] in this toilet You could
argue that you should have that
conversation before you get married fine
you should you could argue that maybe
you should marry someone with similar
you know cleanliness styles to you fine
but what's a better mindset again I go
back to my aunt but you know who am I
who am I you know I'm just a girl with a
podcast no nothing you knew you left it
you want to know why because you flushed
that [__] and you went and like
honestly I I'm okay we can finish the
video honestly like this mindset I just
wonder like what successful marriages
have you seen you know if you ask women
that have been married 20 30 40 50 years
and you ask them is it a valid reason to
get divorced over chores you know you
might maybe maybe the women in your life
would say yes the women in mine
certainly wouldn't
um but let me know what you guys think
in the comments maybe I'm wrong I just
have no real world experience I know
nothing I just say nothing like a child
um let me know like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel ring
that notification Bell and I'll talk to
you next time